wait is that where my head goes okay
just you know if you did like me just
like stretch it a bit and then it's
character alright y'all so if you've
ever scrolled through tick-tock
you know it's filled with super fun
tutorials and trending challenges I have
tried a few let me be a killer key but
since I'm a busy mom I love a good tick
tock hack I've heard about them I
haven't actually seen them so we're
gonna try three hacks today on the app
to see if they are in fact real or not
so let's do this let's do it I'm gonna
play this one
she's got pants oh she's cutting pants
well she's a mom she don't fit in him
anymore
wait she cuts up the back of both sides
wait there's a little butt room ooh wait
what I'm gonna watch one more time you
cut a little part like for a tail and
then okay you don't go all the way down
then you cut up both sides up to like
the buttocks and then she puts it on
like okay let's do this okay so this is
the make leggings into a shirt hack this
is taking you back to like American Idol
when my house burned down I only had one
outfit to wear and I'd made it it wasn't
great but it worked and it worked out
okay wait hold on well we need some like
fabric scissors either one okay now it's
working okay hold on
okay
wah wah and then we go all the way up
here and they didn't go all the way down
so I think they started like here maybe
these are the worst that's our insulin
gonna hold it I mean I think I can get
it to finish this off it's just okay
and they went I believe all the way up
to the buttock it's just fun to see the
struggle at this point okay
okay let's see if I did it I don't know
of like what's front and back but I'm
just gonna go for it
so my head's supposed to go through that
right and I love that I'm putting it on
over this dress so this is a good idea
wait so I maybe did this wrong I'm not
sure I feel like I nailed it
well let's see okay here we go wait
where's your head go wait is that where
my head goes okay just you know if you
did like me just like stretch it a bit
and then it's character so here we go
over this really fancy dress this looks
great
I think I kind of nailed it and now I've
got the ripped look and I feel solid
about it
you see the other sleeve coming out like
a little bit let's fix this let's make
it look even better the other chick
wasn't this cool here we go that is one
I mean is a good hack if you're in a
pinch and you're going to the gym I
don't know that I'd like wear it any
other time okay I'm gonna do this
Doritos one oh she looks fine baby wipes
I like her
okay I like her
here we go okay I like this one I like
this one so can you just tear this off
is that okay
and then you put it on like this but it
but the sticky is not there what are we
to do
oh it the whole thing didn't come on oh
you know what
lesson learned okay wait I've got you
okay okay okay so you put it on like
this then you open it and then you take
a knife or scissors yeah unlike this
party hack I get down with granny that
was cool
I'm taking this with me a pencil a flat
iron okay oh well okay you use the
pencil like a curler or like a little
you know back in the day like little hot
rod things I got that step come here I'd
swear I'm not gonna burn you this is
stuff here we go let's do this I swear
I'm not gonna bend your hair off if I do
I'll buddy some really nice hair to
replace it I'll give you my weave mm-hmm
okay
I'm gonna take the cheap then you do
this okay let's see I didn't want to do
it too long dang that's awesome that's a
good hack you're welcome
give it up for step
alright those are that was awesome the
socks are good this shirt one I probably
wouldn't use but I mean if I need if I
was like working out and like all this
in I don't know I just there's a
perfectly good workout pair of pants
what was good though it worked but
remember to make the hole bigger I don't
know my head was going through there so
I had to stretch it out but then it
looked more rock and roll's - you're
welcome
I enhanced the design alright if you
want to see me do any more things that
make me look stupid on tik-tok just send
them in subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going